hey youtubers it's Charlie and a bunch
of flash fellated stuff has happened
since I posted my arrow of you including
our first look at grant gustin's flash
costume so I'm going to be combining
that with my arrow Q&A if you are
finding me for the first time the flash
TV show has started to blow up so much
that I'm doing weekly videos for that in
addition to my arrow videos so be sure
to subscribe to get everything it's
gonna be a lot of fun just look at it
it's already looking pretty cool so
first let's talk about the new flash
costume and then I'll get to your
questions number one as predicted it's
based on the new 52 version of the suit
the image they released is only of the
mask but I expect the rest of the
costume to look a lot like the new 52
suit it won't be exact but it'll be
really close if you look closely you can
see that the material used makes it look
like a tech suit more than say lycra or
leather like Stephen Amell arrow costume
I totally love the look I think it's
awesome that they're sticking with the
pre-established comic book version
instead of going to Smallville route I
don't expect them to reveal the entire
costume until they're ready to air the
pilot though the CW is airing the
supernatural tribes pilot on the 29th so
there is a strong possibility that they
could also air the flash TV pilot soon
filming just started this week dope but
Grant Gustin and the rest of the cast
have been instagramming the out of
Vancouver
Rick Gosnell who's playing Edward Thawne
aka professor zoom even took a picture
of the vancouver skyline calling it
keystone city the show will take place
in central city but if you're not
familiar though Keystone city is the
origin of the Jay Garrick in Wally West
flashes during Wally West's run as the
main flash Gorilla Grodd and the Rogues
also started attacking Keystone City
instead of Central City it's also the
current location of the flash Museum
after the first one in Central City was
destroyed by the hunter zolomon zoom no
idea yet on how it's going to be
featured in the flash TV show but expect
a lot of Easter eggs hopefully we will
see Grant Gustin in the museum in the
pilot and it would definitely lend some
credence to the theory that John Wesley
Shipp is playing the Jay Garrick
character I'll report more about what's
happening at the set in a video next
week but let me know what are your
reactions to grant gustin's flash
costume totally awesome I know but let's
get your questions may just three six
nine one asks what will happen to Laurel
now that she is cleaning yourself up and
when will they have Roy Moore involved
with the arrow team so she's probably
gonna start pursuing brother blood again
I think that the show is going to give
her the satisfaction
taking him down and Roy will be a big
part of next week's episode the promise
I'll probably talk more about Roy in a
predictions video for that episode
question number two le camel asks when
do you think that the flash TV show will
start airing so the expectation is that
it will air back-to-back with arrow
whenever it comes back in the fall just
so we can benefit from that built-in
audience since arrow is already really
early they would probably air flash
after it typically when they do things
like that the bigger show goes first to
draw in more eyeballs hoping that
they'll stick around for whatever's next
that's why they put that brand-new show
The Tomorrow People right after arrow
this season question number three Scott
smart asks if this doesn't get an A from
you what kind of episode will so you're
just asking about my rating for the
episode I typically try to reserve a s
for like the best things of all things
that I watched so I don't just compare
episodes of arrow to other episodes of
arrow I'm comparing it to Walking Dead
game of Thrones Doctor Who everything
else I watched ideally there would only
be like a few a's per season but just
because it didn't give it an 8 doesn't
mean it was awesome i did love the
episode question number 4 mage the
badass asks do you think that slade will
turn roy to his side or at least try yes
i think you or someone else made the
anakin skywalker emperor comment he'll
definitely try but the funny thing about
arrow is like most comic book stories
it's not super hard to predict the
outcome he'll almost turn roy and then
in the hour of need he'll rally back to
the good side in this case though no I
think Roy will go a little bit nuts but
he's not gonna start working for Slade
question number 5
Joe Kerr asks are Blue Beetle Metal Men
or Booster Gold going to make an
appearance so yeah there have been a lot
of cord industries Easter eggs this
season they do have stuff in development
but in terms of who would come on first
I would say Ted Kord and it would play
out like the Grant Gustin episodes he'd
reveal himself as Blue Beetle to oliver
over the course of a two-part episode
Booster Gold is also really high in the
list of people I think Geoff Johns would
like to see on the show they usually
reserved big news like that for Comic
Con so you can't expect to find out
who's coming on the show next season in
a couple months question number six
Lexus Dre R asks do you think that
Laurel finally deciding in no uncertain
terms to grow up was because of what
Oliver said to her about having loved
her half his life but that he was
finally done so I think that she was
already on the fence but I think that he
just kind of pushed her over
think it was mostly Sara and her family
that we're helping her but he did kind
of verbally slap some sense into her so
he was a big part of that but he wasn't
the main reason question number seven
Rick Grimes asks do you think the team
arrow will try to fight Slade next
episode but then get badly beaten you're
not looking so good Rick you should
definitely put a bandaid on that I think
that Oliver's face is gonna look like
your face after next episode
unsurprisingly Roy is also supposed to
get his ass kicked
question number eight Smoak and arrow
says I think that Slade hacked the phone
to lure Oliver there so he was totally
caught off guard by Slade's presence
yeah that was weird I think that was
either Slade manipulating him or Thea
did get kidnapped and she was just
trying to get Oliver his help we'll find
out next week question number nine
my master asks will Felicity train a bit
or something sort of like that yes the
writer said that Felicity will continue
to train with Diggle but we're not gonna
get any montages like we got last week
it is implied that she'll be learning
how to physically defend herself she
will continue to be wonderfully clumsy
though question number ten Lee slay
dragons asks do you think that Slade's I
will corrupt those he loves refers to
Sara with the Huntress or Moira I
definitely think that he's going to try
and kill Sara in his speech he said kill
those who follow him I think that when
he talked about those he loves he was
just talking about his family
so Thea and Moira the funny thing is is
that Maura is already one of the most
corrupt people on the show and one last
bonus question the Dean Theory asks will
there ever be a time when the island
story is finished and the present-day
stories keep going remember when they
told the island story from Sara's
perspective I think that they'll do a
little bit more of that but it was on
the island for five years which is a
long time so they will get creative and
add some new dimensions to the island
stories I'm also hoping someday that
they'll tell flashback stories for
Sara's training with the League of
Assassins
thank you so much for submitting your
questions guys this was a lot of fun as
always I'm sure you thought of a billion
new questions about the costume while I
was making this video feel free to write
them in the comments and we'll try and
answer them there so remember next week
is huge supposedly the promise the
episode is supposed to make the season
one finale look like a really crappy
student film be sure to subscribe to get
my video I also might do a predictions
video if you guys want in the next
couple
right now click here to get my review of
the arrow episode and click here to get
my latest flash video thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you